take it fake it come on the stupid
machine won't take my dollar that's half
a dollar taped to a pizza coupon it's
good for a cheesy bread worth two
dollars and fifty cents you would have
made money on this deal machine a year
ago today peralta and i made a bet to
prove who's a better detective whoever
makes more felony arrests wins oh what
are the stakes and don't say money
because i know you're in debt oh if you
really knew anything about me you would
have said crushing debt and i'll bet
whatever cause there's no way i'm losing
i think a pigeon just flew out of your
car yeah the windows don't exactly roll
up
the car's a piece of crap why do you
love it so much
you really want to know
i was two days out of the academy super
nervous saw this guy run out of a bodega
clutching a bunch of cash so i pursued
him on foot 11 blocks
finally catch him cuff him throw him up
against
that car
turned out there was a for sale sign in
the window and it being the best day of
my life i bought it
thus began the debt
crushing debt
you do know me oh peralta where have you
been i'm sorry i'm sorry i know i am
35 minutes late yikes but i had to stop
and get some wine
hello good sir i'd like your finest
bottle of wine please that will be
sixteen hundred dollars great i'd like
your eight dollarist bottle of wine
please
it's from the finest vineyard in
arkansas
oh
samesies hey sarge can i borrow a dollar
no
no more loans you already owe me way too
much the bank of terry is closed what
are you sailing away on a tugboat man i
love tugboats it's not a tugboat i'm
locking the vault all right fine how
much could i possibly owe you 50 60
bucks 2
437
dollars
wait of course dollars why was that the
part i was surprised by jay i would
appreciate it if you paid me back
well
that's the craziest thing anyone's ever
said to me i would appreciate it if you
paid me back good so you heard it too
i've been in debt to him forever and
he's never cared before something's up
i'm gonna drop everything and figure out
why he's acting weird or you could just
pay him what you owe
hilarious rosa
hilarious
now i have a question for you is there
any way i can borrow 430 000 why on
earth do you need that much money i need
to buy my apartment i've been living at
my nana's place since she passed away
because it's rent controlled but now the
building's going co-op so i have to buy
it i need to secure a loan by the end of
the day uh so should we do a wire
transfer or do you think cash is easier
let's just do cash shouldn't you be
asking somebody else for that kind of
money like a bank yeah i tried that
[Music]
[Laughter]
so talk to me goose how we looking sexy
but not like we're trying too hard like
sure we're trying but it's almost
effortless yeah no i knew all of that i
meant the money thing oh
my first impression is that you have a
debilitating spending problem
jake you have six massage chairs well
they don't make a massage couch okay but
you also have three turntables ooh yeah
i'm learning how to spin check it out
all i have are my grandma's old klezmer
records and i still haven't quite
figured out how to sync up the beats but
it's not bad right it's awful it sounds
like joy baer falling down some stairs
okay you also purchased olympus has
fallen on demand 12 times was it a
difficult movie for you to follow no
just watched it a lot so hit me how much
do i have to cut back in order to keep
this place infinity percent
technically speaking you're bankrupt
kiddo that sounds bad it is bad i only
said kiddo to soften the blow kiddo
[Music]
there you are sergeant installment one
of tbd 1200 bucks that's everything i
have you should also note it's all in
singles because it takes so many bills
to fill up a briefcase thanks peralta
what's going on
how'd you get all that money
by putting bad guys behind bars i work
for a living geez
i emptied out my checking account wait
you vote terry for years and now
suddenly you give him every penny you
have
why why
oh wait
because that is not an answer no well
because
you guys got in my head about owing
terry money and it convinced me that
it's important to pay back your friends
well you owe all of us money so does
that mean you're gonna pay all of us
back yeah jake or is there something
special about your friendship with terry
nope nothing special about terry i'm
gonna pay everyone man i really hope to
say this to a drug dealer who killed my
whole family but
it's payback time
[Music]
attention everyone say goodbye to the
jake peralta you know and love for today
is the day i forever change
ooh are you finally growing a mustache
no you know i can't do that and it's
cruel of you to keep bringing it up this
envelope contains the inheritance my
uncle left me he died a year ago he was
so rich he had a whole room in his house
just to eat him you mean like a dining
room yeah but in manhattan oh dang now
just because i'm definitely rich now
doesn't mean i'm gonna forget my roots
you all get something so fire away jake
your friendship is gift enough for me
friendship is crap i want a ducati
monster 821. all right rosa gets a
motorcycle oh cool i want a fast sports
car come on you could be honest i want
old expensive books i'll send you a list
there you go now let's find out what i'm
worth
uh i'm too nervous to open it sarge you
do it okay
it's stock one million shares oh my god
blockbuster video stuff oh
what is that bad
i still have a blockbuster card
what happened to blockbuster i don't
need much just like 430 000
nah too much
i make small loans to desperate losers
and friends like you well i'm happy this
went terribly uh we do have to go now so
please excuse us wait i just need enough
to show the co-op board i can make a
down payment at the bank how about
twenty thousand dollars two bags of
zitty
that i can do
bags of ziti come on gina how awesome is
that get on board come on gina get on
board jake he is a sea witch in disguise
do not sing into his shell i have no
idea what you're talking about right now
oh little mermaid what have you done
i know there's been a lot of
misconceptions about my financial
situation but i am ready to put that to
rest right now boom goes the dynamite oh
my god that's twenty thousand dollars
right there and i intend to use it as a
down payment on a mortgage where did you
get this money just had a lying around
put a nice little dent into my terry
debt
no applause seriously okay see how this
is gonna be all right how much do i owe
the rest of you four thousand and nine
dollars what how is that even possible
june 3rd 2008 paid free lunch 8.45
june 3rd 2008 bought you soda dollar
five cents june 3rd 2008 lent you four
thousand dollars for an entertainment
system yeah there it is stop keeping
track after that sure sure okay how
about the rest of you uh seven hundred
and ten dollars
856 dollars and 32 cents okay very
specific i'm sorry you guys but i can't
pay that it's too much money why don't
you just take back the money you gave to
terry and split it six ways and at least
everyone gets something yeah but terry
needs the money for what uh
for butt enhancement surgery smart
that's a real problem area for terry
yeah what what i am not having butt
enhancement surgery nor do i need it
okay so split up the money no no no how
about this
i'll work off my debt to each of you
how's that sound i'll do anything you
want
anything
am i the only one that was super creeped
out by that no that was definitely
creepy yeah he wants you to do something
real weird it's the rest of the money i
owe you 1237 bucks i thought you already
drained your bank account i sold my car
it's not a big deal
oh my god this is such a huge deal
you